I like coming up with things that
haven't been asked so I'm curious uh
right now there's been a bunch of things
that have been announced about Star Wars
or movie the different series that are
coming how many things are you guys
working on behind the scenes that have
actually not been announced yet that are
like in pre-production active
development
um
what time is it I'm just kidding I'm
just kidding now
um you know I think it's something new
for Star Wars that that we do have a
development system and there are lots of
things that we're discussing uh or
reading all the time I can't say how
many but you know we're always looking
for let me ask you this new creatives
and new stories is there like but there
are things you guys are developing that
have are not public
sure is it a lot or a little
sure okay
um I actually don't know how many
episodes uh Ahsoka is so how many
episodes is it I know
right well I showed how many directors
there are but sometimes people do more
than one episode I know very good that's
true I'll say this
I did more than one episode which makes
sense you know I I you know
am I saying how many
episodes but you know director so you
have a good idea of how many there so
I'm guessing it's between eight and ten
it's a good guess that's what I figure
yeah um are there are the runtimes
similar to Mandalorian so they could be
like 30 minutes to 45 or they're any
that are an hour
yeah that's an interesting question you
know I would say it's pretty relative
when you do this kind of work one thing
John and I are very adamant about is we
try to you know cut it down and strip it
down to keep it moving you know it's
very much a faster more intense rule
that George has so my episodes have
actually started pretty long you know
because I wrote them all so they're a
little different I probably they're
relative to other stuff that I've
written and done but like like the
episode the Jedi you know but if it's
got to be tight and fast because they
need the action to work it's going to be
shorter but I would say they're in the
same range as Mandalorian episodes maybe
on average a little longer but I I
honestly don't know where they're at
right now their most recent cut down
I've done but I'd say it's in the same
range I mean I like long episodes as
much as anybody as long as it's moving
you know 100 did you write all the up
who wrote the episodes I wrote them all
yeah yeah yeah that was a lot of a lot
of work so I just know the characters
well so I had to do it I always let me
ask you one last thing
um I'm looking at my my questions
um a lot of people haven't seen Rebels
and they're gonna come into this series
and I'm curious what arcs on Rebels
should people watch prior to watching
your series
you know I don't think you wouldn't need
to watch any uh you really should
they're all available on Disney plus so
you can check them out there and that
would be great but uh you know
I don't know I I for me if you really
were interested in and if it got people
that maybe don't aren't as interested in
animation into it I would start uh
probably like maybe like the episode
Jedi Knight where the sad thing happens
to Kanan even if you didn't understand
what that was it would Propel you for it
if you just watch season four you'd be
set you can start with that and you get
that these Rebels are fighting this
tyrannical Empire and that that would
get you everything and everybody you
need you don't need to do the entire
gamut of rebels but you should once you
watch that you're gonna be like well I
don't have to watch it all so you know
that happened we watched my wife and I
watched the show Endeavor and then we
ended up watching all of Inspector
Morris because we wanted to see all that
and then we watched Lewis as well so
it's like a condominal on you and that's
the beauty of streaming now too is it's
available to you you know so as you
watch something if you really like
Sabine you can go and and see more about
her so I think there's a benefit there
but yeah I've been very aware of the
fact of like trying to write these
things that you don't need to have seen
any of it not that I don't want you to I
want you to but you don't have to yeah